哈囉 新年快樂呀 大家今天是30萬粉絲福利
感謝每一位一路以來陪伴
支持我的粉絲寶貝們
那我也不是很特別的打這些所謂
咱們就直接用筆誤來表示吧
我一共給大家準備了66個禮物
66個寶貝
有服同想
首先是一個iC Watch的S11
考慮到關注我的姐妹拜
分之99都是女生
所以我選了42毫米的營色表盤
更好的搭配表袋
還有兩個平國耳機iPhone 4
是降噪版的
還有三個拍裏格的
米米12
它這個椅盒也非常漂亮
裡面有一個相機包照片夾
還有花花箱紙
我還單獨又配了一顆箱紙
所以希望大家收到能夠多拍能力的照片
還有搭份盒子
每個裡面都有我最喜歡的CPB的面片
熟悉我的姐妹都知道
這個是我家庭版身層清潔的運用化中免
非常非常好用
還有一個Hello Kitty的掛鍵
它是超可愛的黑皮支付款
我當時把他們店裡面
這個款所謂的庫存全部都買完了
這兩個組合的盒子
我一共會抽8的姐妹
接下來一共是22個禮盒
我就直接給大家看一看
首先是一個戰演的
看看哇
這是兩個塑修精髮
還有藍膜
還有一盒口罩
還有他們家的一個
塑修精髮米
丹蟲蛋白的修護組
下面還有什麼東西
這個大家都抽到了姐妹
自己拿回去開吧
第二個
這個是T走的禮盒
應該是他們家內盤
有下面雙這個是Light的顛色
我之前我自己跟妳的是這個
防疫白黃二白的姐妹
就可以跟妳說吧
還有一個他們家的姐妹
好
這一個是打耳符他們家裡合
看看這裡是什麼
哇
好幽黏味
就是缺話
這個是
這一個應該是他們家的那個泡光水
然後這個是他們家的西人酸
或者他們家的應該是新品
一個人的
就是刺泡精華
這一個是A9扣的他們的禮盒
然後我們來看看哇塞
有眼窗
還有眼窗
原容窗超好弱的
他們家的DNA的那個也是刺泡
這個
我將原泡來囉
一盒將原泡在裡面
還有一個
檢驗
進去拆這個
哇我是歐勒的禮盒業
都好漂亮
好幽黏味
這應該是他們家的麵爽
這應該是他們家的白白精華
然後這是一個
對來
這個是
不是寶寗
這是一個安心酷
裡面呢
然後是他們家的夜期的衛生金
到了我非常熟悉的
律州了
有一個
250好深的
律州精華
將當於是
89隻
正妝律州精華的樣子
好可愛
裡面還有他們家的律州麵爽
很好用裡面爽
哇
這個是嗎
這是迷森唐的禮盒
好好看啊
就去買
哇塞
這個是
他們家的
紅色密入精華業
我穿愛的這件爽
還有他們家的一個
月威的麵爽
應該是那個
交園碰麵爽
劉禮系列的精華業
這個的話呢
我自己想試一下
這個很頓利路的
對吧
拿出來
然後眼刷麵爽
還有這個
劉禮的精華業
都放在盒子裡面
好好看
就逼成這件的盒子
看一下裡面
這是一個他們家的
後臉皮的
新武雙
後臉皮的精華水
哇
這是他們和
比較火的麵味
還有一個他們家的
後臉皮的一個麵鍋
再來
哇塞
這一個
也受待馬的盒子
好看下是什麼
裡面有紅酒
然後
這個是一個
他們家的精華油
然後就是這個酒杯
應該是水果料包
如果大家要煮熱紅酒的話
它都幫大家點安排好了
這件是
一生至眼它們家的
這是他們家的
一個後臉皮的精華油
這個也是他們家的一個精華油
這個精華油應該就是
你們把這個打開之後
灌到這個屏幕這裡
這個是一顆每個
一次性的焦片機
它這邊也是可以用12次的
顆麵湯
他們家的
顆麵湯家的
盒子呢
有兩個
他們家的
都頂眼霜
超愛的
然後他們家的泥蘿
我也很喜歡用
還有他們家的某孔精華
以及某孔精華水
非常地沾濕
哇
這個是三次的
每次它們三次的很好看
這應該是一個
香豆還是一個辣植
這是一個小零千包
這個是他們家的一個
包塔精華的麵霜
也是他們家的
包塔精華的一個麵霜
兩層麵霜
很漂亮
這個盒子很喜歡
哇
看看的
澳洲的麵湯
是什麼
有兩層精華
然後有一個
他們家的咖啡
的眼部精華
還有一個柳黃豆豆粉
這個應該很適合
這個是背致的禮盒
但是這個是有素風的
這個我就不給大家拆了
到時候直接就抽給寶貝們
這個是加麵芒的禮盒
加麵芒
它每次也是做的
非常非常的刷的禮盒
一共四個層雙
兩個就是它版的
粉餅
三個粉餅
雙
這個是一個湯在掛鍵
超好看
最後兩個呢
是這個薄薄打的禮盒
這都是沒拆過的
到時候的話
有一個剪淚的
這個可能是
所以我打開了
哇
首先是他們家的柳芙水
還有他們家的
應該是三次精華吧
我知道
我覺得應該是三次精華
就是它上面就是
資氧修徒精華
然後這個是一個
換眼亮噴精華
水洋酸的一個麵膜
還有一個冷芙飲
好的
裡面還有一個小暴震
這個好像是一個精緣寶的樣子
還有一個優飛斯的禮盒
他們家的修復雙
說安噴霧
還有一個他們家的安獎環算
感謝剛才的品牌媽媽們
一共是22個禮盒
我會在這條視頻裡面
能抽使購
還有12個盒
都會放在我的380
只剩兩場當中抽掉
那大家記得點好預約
到時候我們只國間剪
那我還準備了
三十個戶品
比如說都比壓
三修壓
還有很多島出業
這些到時候會抽30個剪
沒隨機
在這三個
戶婦品當中發一個
那我最後說一下
我們的參與方式
就是在這個視頻下六連
關注電飯收藏評論點好
然後還有我們左下角的預約
那以上的所有的抽獎
我們都會在380結束之後
最晚4月給大家全部發出
最後還是非常非常感謝
各位此美的支持和培辦
希望大家天天開心